so good morning to you it's seven
o'clock in the uk nine o'clock here in
the ukrainian capital kiev our breaking
news this morning
it's war president putin announces the
start of a military operation
explosions heard in the ukrainian
capital kiev as well as the eastern city
of kharkiv
minutes after president putin made his
announcement for the start of his
military offensive
[Music]
i decided to conduct a special military
operation
its goal is the protection of the people
who for eight years suffered from abuse
and genocide from the kiev regime
[Music]
ukrainian tanks and soldiers have been
taking up positions on the streets of
the eastern city of mariopol as the
president declares martial law here
do not panic we are strong we are ready
for everything and we will defeat
everyone because we are ukraine
glory to ukraine
[Music]
russia's assault began as the un
security council held an emergency
session overnight
this is
the saddest moment
in my
channel
the secretary general of the united
nations
boris johnson will chair a cobra meeting
at half past seven this morning to
discuss the uk's response
[Music]
of course we'll bring you the latest as
we get it with our correspondence in the
ukrainian capital kiev as well as
kharkiv on the eastern border of ukraine
the russian capital to moscow also from
brussels from outside downing street and
from
the united states
good morning from the ukrainian capital
kiev gunfire and explosions have been
heard here and in the second city of
kharkiv shortly after the russian
president vladimir putin authorized a
special military operation in ukraine's
donbass region and told the ukrainian
military to lay down their weapons and
go home
in a special televised address on
russian state tv mr putin said russia
had been left with no choice but to
defend itself against what he said were
threats from ukraine
this is what we know so far in moscow
vladimir putin announced the military
operation just before 3 am uk time at
the same time an emergency meeting of
the security council was taking place in
new york
as president putin spoke before dawn big
explosions were heard on the outskirts
of kiev kharkiv odessa and other cities
across ukraine there are reports that
russian troops have landed in mariopol
and odessa they have not been confirmed
ukrainian president vladimir zelensky
has declared martial law in ukraine and
told people to stay home
well since then we've had a series of
developments uh throughout the morning
air raid sirens have been heard here in
the capital kiev though we are told they
are tests at the moment in the donetsk
region russian-backed separatists say
they have launched what they call
massive strikes against ukrainian forces
more recently the ukrainian military say
their air defense system shot down five
russian planes and one russian
helicopter in the luhansk region though
the russians have denied that that has
happened and in the uk the prime
minister boris johnson is expected to
convene that cobra committee meeting i
was talking about at a half past seven
this morning
let's listen back to that special
address on russian television by
vladimir putin in the early hours of
this morning
i decided to conduct a special military
operation
its goal is the protection of the people
who for eight years suffered from abuse
and genocide from the kiev regime
we urge you to lay down arms immediately
and go home
i will explain
all servicemen of the ukrainian army who
comply with this requirement can freely
leave the area of military action and
return to their families
whoever would try to stop us and further
create threats to our country to our
people should know that russia's
response will be immediate and lead you
to such consequences that you have never
faced in your history
we are ready for any outcome
well a few hours ago ukraine's president
vladimir zelensky declared martial law
here and he urged citizens not to panic
as russia launched their military
strikes
let's take a look at what he said in a
video posted on his social media
channels
dear ukrainians
this morning president putin announced a
special military operation in the
donbass russia carried out strikes on
our military infrastructure on our
border guards explosions were heard in
many cities of ukraine we introduced
martial law throughout the state
a minute ago i had a conversation with
president biden the u.s is starting to
gather international support
today we need you
each of you to be calm
if possible stay at home please we are
working the army is working the entire
security and defense sector of ukraine
is working
i the national security and defense
council the government will be in touch
soon i will be in touch again
do not panic we are strong we are ready
for everything and we will defeat
everyone because we are ukraine
glory to ukraine
president zielinski talking to the
people of ukraine there western leaders
have been reacting
to what has happened this morning the
prime minister boris johnson he tweeted
this i am appalled by the horrific
events in ukraine and i have spoken to
president zielinski to discuss the next
steps
president putin has chosen a path of
bloodshed and destruction by launching
this unprovoked attack on ukraine the uk
and our allies will respond decisively
in the united states u.s president joe
biden said the prayers of the entire
world are with the people of ukraine as
they suffer an unprovoked and
unjustified attack by russian military
forces mr biden said president putin has
chosen a premeditated war that will
bring a catastrophic loss of life and
human suffering and that the world will
hold russia accountable
the u.s president says he will be
monitoring the situation from the white
house and will continue to get regular
updates from his national security team
he says he will meet with his g7
counterparts
in the morning
in europe european commission president
ursula van der lion says in these dark
hours our thoughts are with ukraine and
the innocent women men and children as
they face this unprovoked attack and
fear for their lives
the ukrainian foreign minister dimitrio
kulaiba has urged the world to act
immediately warning that the future of
europe and the world was at stake he's
called for devastating sanctions as he
put it on russia
now and for russia to be fully isolated
he also called for
more weapons equipment financial and
humanitarian assistance
for
ukraine the german chancellor olaf
schultz said russia must stop this
military action immediately
today he said we will coordinate closely
within the framework of the g7 nato and
the eu mr schultz added this is a
terrible day for ukraine and a dark day
for europe
so
let's have a look at the map the map
that shows uh the rebel-held areas of
donetsk and luhansk
there we are
that's the center of all this down in
southeastern ukraine's donbass region
earlier this week russia recognized the
regions as independent from ukraine and
signed friendship treaties with both of
them
ukraine considers them and
the un considers them temporarily
occupied territories
but russia say they are theirs and
they annexed crimea
and uh to the south of donetsk is mario
pole which lies outside of the
rebel-held area
but this morning reports of at least two
blasts have been heard
in that city so clearly
a lot of action going on down there
debra haynes is
with me and so deborah i mean that we
could see there the map of
donetsk and a lot of action clearly
going on there and this was the
justification used by putin but just
give us
as you know it what is what is happening
in this country
well yeah in terms of that justification
you heard president putin talking about
genocide which is just completely false
he's created this false narrative to
justify what he's done uh saying that
there's been like these attacks in the
east and that the ukrainian government
poses that threat which is just not true
and and in terms of what
i'm just i do apologize i'm going to
we're just going to lose a guest as a
ukrainian mp i will come straight back
to you lesia vasilenko is a member of
the uk of the ukrainian parliament in
kiev and she can speak to us now and can
you just give us first of all your
reaction
to what is happening to your country
this morning
okay well first of all uh i'd like to
say that it's not separatist held areas
or whatever the terminology you were
using these are ukrainian territories
which are occupied today not by
separatists but by russian army
irregular forces of the russian military
and also regular russian military which
has broken ukrainian borders which is
bombing ukrainian airports and
which is literally marching on to kiev
and other cities so this must be very
clear we're not talking about any kind
of civil war or any hints at civil war
literally ukraine is at war a war which
was declared by russia at 5 00 a.m this
morning kiev time officially and uh 3
a.m uk time but also uh a war which has
started several hours before that when
the first shellings uh of eastern parts
of ukraine have started so uh i urge you
all please the media the international
community politicians to use the proper
language there are no separatists these
are russian military which are attacking
a sovereign independent country which is
merely fighting for the right to exist
absolutely and what do you
uh think that president putin
wants to achieve here
well it is clear he doesn't want ukraine
to exist as as is he is either going to
destroy our country physically or he is
going to destroy us politically by
putting pressure now on the people
keeping the people in fear and making
sure that the politician like the
politicians like myself come into
parliament and vote for ridiculous
decisions uh saying that ukraine will
never be part of nato saying that
ukraine uh
admits that crimea is russian and
whatever other uh complete madness that
he has in his mind in order to rebuild
his russian empire and this is the crazy
world that we live in today just this
morning i've been up since uh 5 30 a.m
uh time and at 7 00 am i was already in
the radar prepared to vote for the
martial law and we voted the martial law
in ukraine is in a state of war a war
declared by russia on ukraine and which
started back in 2014 with russian
aggression
and what are your fears this morning for
the people of this country
the fears are clear airports are being
bombed and
scaled as these are
well i'm sorry we seem to have uh lost
alessia vesselenko there but
i mean she was absolutely clear and it
is a valid point that we're talking
about separatists we were just doing so
before she came on and i mean there are
separatists there and they've been there
for eight years or so but now
there are russian troops on ukrainian
soil and she makes the point that they
are now
clearly at war with russia yes and
there's been a statement from the
president describing what he says has
been happening to his country and
actually the mp just made that point
there as well that this uh this attack
as operation began at five o'clock local
time and the president said that there
had been um
intensive shelling against units in the
east which is close to where that
occupied territory is and also missiles
missile strikes on airfields in um boris
pill which is the airport area close to
kiev
and also other areas including
kramertorsk which is in the east of the
country and against military
infrastructure we don't yet have a full
breakdown of what exactly has been hit
and he's very adamant that the ukrainian
armed forces are responding um but it
gives you a just a sense of what
actually happened this morning what we
all woke up to when we heard these
explosions that we could hear from the
centre of kiev in terms of the attack
actually beginning um but it seems that
it did all start to unfold at five
o'clock this morning and clearly the mp
there and many others in ukraine will be
fearing the worst case scenario
they will and it's it's been it's almost
been like um a narrative that's just
what it was what the west had said would
happen all along and it's been unfolding
um gradually and then suddenly building
up this this creation of a crisis in the
east this is a country that's been in
conflict for eight years let's not
forget that russia invaded ukraine
already back in 2014 when it annexed
crimea and as that mp was saying backed
what we describe as these separatists in
the east of the country i think we can
see some pictures actually from crimea
i'm being told well and crimea as well
is a key staging post now in this
operation we've known over the last few
weeks that um
russia has built up
its troop presence on that peninsula as
well as some 150 000 troops around this
country it's more than 60 percent of
russia's entire combat power and in
terms of the air power it's more than
half of the air power it's got it at its
disposal for this operation we've seen
those satellite images with field
hospitals blood supplies all the kind of
infrastructure and logistics chain that
you would also need to launch an
operation and yes like i was saying the
the narrative that's been built up
information used as a weapon as much as
missiles and bombs in this conflict uh
you've had the russians claiming that
ukraine's armed forces pose a threat to
civilians ethnic russians in donetsk and
luhansk regions you had them bust out
taken out of those regions under this
supposed threat no independently
verifiable evidence of any threat
ukraine's government says it's not true
and yet that is the justification that
president putin is giving to his people
as he launches this operation to try to
protect people whereas actually he's
creating a huge crisis in what had been
a peaceful country that doesn't pose a
threat
okay let's uh bring in james cleverley
uh who is in
westminster
and uh
james cleverly i think uh
uh foreign office minister yes we can
talk to you uh so your reaction first of
all
to what is unfolding here where we are
this morning
well mark sadly what we're seeing
is the situation in ukraine playing out
unfortunately as we feared it might and
as we predicted it would
vladimir putin has used
disinformation he's used lies he's used
false flag activities to justify the
unjustifiable which is an invasion
of ukraine
in response to this the the uk will in
close alignment with our international
partners uh bring forward an
unprecedented level of sanctions to
punish this aggression
and to hopefully persuade
the people around vladimir putin that
this is a completely the wrong thing to
do
and that he should reverse this attack
the prime minister spoke with the
ukrainian president um foreign secretary
spoke with her opposite number i've
spoken with the ambassador we stand we
continue to stand shoulder to shoulder
with the ukrainian people
but uh president putin will almost
certainly have factored in
uh the new round of sanctions that
you know is going to come as you say
and he doesn't seem to mind he seems to
think he's just going to get on with
what he wants to do and he doesn't seem
to care about sanctions
well we've already seen the ruble
collapse on the international markets
that will have a meaningful impact
on russia
the people the institutions that prop
him up
even if vladimir putin doesn't care the
people around him will feel this and
they absolutely will care
the
the decision
to invade a ukraine as i say completely
unprovoked completely unjustified and it
will be met with an unprecedented
response from the international
community
you've been providing in the west and
the united states has been providing
lots of intelligence about what he his
forces are doing on the border and what
his plans are
that sort of intelligence has been
announced openly by joe biden
what is the intelligence at the moment
about what president putin is out to
achieve here
well sadly president putin has been
really clear in what he's trying to
achieve he is trying to
recreate
a
a russian empire in his mind claim back
places which he defines as russia but
the international community recognizes
that these are
individual sovereign states ukraine is
not part of russia
and the uh the fantasy that vladimir
putin is trying to play out
recreating some kind of tsarist
expansionist
russia absolutely has to be stopped and
we will continue working we've been
providing financial and military support
to
ukraine for um
for a number of years um just yesterday
the foreign sector announced an economic
uh support package there will of course
be more
support and we will be bringing forward
as i say uh in close concert with our
international friends and allies an
unprecedented
uh sanctions response coordinated
sanctions response to
to punish this appalling decision
but is your understanding or
intelligence that he wants to remove the
government here and
control
the whole of ukraine
well
the
the excuses that he's been uh giving the
justifications that he's giving uh
cannot be uh cannot be believed
uh we do of course um
fear that he might try and do something
as reckless as that we will of course
continue to push back and what i would
say
is that the military leaders around
vladimir putin they must know that this
is a catastrophically
bad judgment call by vladimir putin
ukraine is a huge country physically i
have no doubt the ukrainian people will
be ferocious in defense of their
homeland
and the the military leaders must know
that this will come at a huge cost
not just ukrainians but to uh russians
and they are
uh they are in a position even if
vladimir putin won't they are in a
position to stop this and call upon them
to do so
and can anything else be done
to stop him now this is well underway um
and is the position still very clear
that uh
um nato troops will not be fighting in
ukraine
well
ukraine is is is not a nato country we
will of course
uh give support to the ukrainians in
their own self-defense
uh nato uh the the relationship of nato
member states is different to that uh to
the one we have with ukraine but we will
of course support the ukrainians
in defending themselves the prime
minister is
chairing a meeting of cobra i think
almost
imminently
where decisions about how that support
will manifest itself and he will also be
speaking to other world leaders as will
the foreign secretary as will i in terms
of our
coordinated support
to ukraine and our coordinative
coordinated punitive sanctions towards
russia
and just finally um
nato states can you
uh guarantee that nato states if
threatened once he does what he wants to
do with ukraine will be defended
i'll be under absolutely no doubt the
solidarity of nato is unwavering
um and that's why uh the uk
and indeed other um
nato member states have been moving
troops to our eastern nato allies
so absolutely nato will stand shoulder
shoulder with its members but we will
also continue to support the legitimate
government of ukraine to support the
people of ukraine in their self-defense
against this unprovoked aggression from
vladimir putin
okay james cleverley thank you for
being with us this morning
let's go down uh to uh the southeastern
ukraine now mario pole the port city
there alex rossi uh joins me now um and
alex do you have any idea from what
you're seeing what you're hearing down
there uh what is going on
it is a very confusing picture here mark
world leaders have described this as a
dark day for ukraine it's certainly very
gloomy down here in mario pool there's a
an incessant rain coming in now and uh
it's hard to work out what exactly is
going on now there have been reports
that there has been a russian amphibious
uh landing we've seen no evidence of
that at all it could be further up the
coast we're hearing
every so often that the sound of
explosions it's very hard again to tell
whether that's incoming fire or outgoing
fire it's hard to tell
whether or not it's air strikes
i think it's probably the sound
of artillery but a very very
odd place to be at the moment and you
look around here there are still cars on
the road
in this direction about 20 kilometers
away there are the front lines now we
are seeing
most of the traffic coming away there's
villages along that area coming away
into the city of mariopol uh which is up
this road there are a few cars going
this way
but not many at all we've also seen
as well this morning quite a few
ambulances coming back from the front
towards
the city now just to give you an idea
where we are this is the steel works
behind me
just over my right shoulder on this side
you see you can perhaps just make out
the sea of azov now this is a port city
it's an industrial center it's
strategically
extremely uh important now significantly
it is also within the donbass albeit
under ukrainian control now according to
the constitution
of the russian-backed separatists they
claim this is their territory so this
would be a place that you'd expect to be
taken quite quickly
in this russian invasion of ukraine but
people here
they're waiting they're extremely
nervous it's really odd actually i've
been here for
i've been here for 10 days now and
certainly
for the first seven or eight of those
days
most people were really quite
disbelieving of the intelligence being
uh put out there into the public by uh
western intelligence agencies they just
didn't think this happened of course
they recognized this mass buildup of
russian troops
and armor on their borders but things
changed
significantly after that really quite
odd
described by soldiers who listened to it
crazy speech by vladimir putin a few
days ago and i think people did start to
believe that this um
would happen and of course they're
waiting very nervously
to see what happens i've seen a few
people out in town
spoken to a few people they're pretty
scared
other people we've seen scuttling
back into their homes with bags of
shopping
stocking up really in the event that
they may have to hunker down for the
next few days weeks
how long this will go on of course
nobody knows
alex i should just say stay with me a
second i should just say that the
ukrainians are reporting that eight
people
have uh
been killed and nine wounded in the
attacks on this country uh so far and
alex you were just hinting there at how
important a strategic area that is mario
pol
he also of course has crimea already
just explain
in more detail why that is so important
to him down there
well it's an industrial center it's also
a port city for so from for from that
point of view uh it's nestled on the sea
of azov it would be an important place
to take it's also within the donetsk
oblast under as i was saying ukrainian
control at the moment so that would make
it a significant strategic target
for the russians but also
from the east and parts
of the the country so from western
russia coming in you would also need to
take this place to create a land bridge
to crimea which of course vladimir putin
took control of and annexed in 2014 so
from that point of view it is extremely
significant now there are
you know various uh theories as to how
vladimir putin will will launch this
attack it's early days we don't yet
really know what uh he is planning to do
it would appear that there is an
invasion taking place across the country
now you could see a massive column of
armor pushing up from the crimea that
would cut ukraine pretty much in half
remember that most of the ukrainian
military is pivoted toward pivoted
towards the eastern front and it would
effectively decapitate
kiev remember that in this conflict uh
kiev is the center of gravity that is
what you'd have to
take out if you were going to take
control of the whole country
so dark and difficult days
for ukraine
people
really waiting as i was saying extremely
nervously here now i was up in a village
called buryansk it's about 18 kilometers
from where we are standing here
in this direction now that place
uh was
attacked continuously from 2014 onwards
there were significant attacks in 2016.
there are a few people living there
at the moment
but most people
most people have left
and
we've also saw quite a few ukrainian
soldiers
in the buildings there as well now it's
areas like that along the coastline that
would perhaps be places that you could
see an amphibious assault
by russian marines as well as the the
land uh forces coming in uh from the
south of crimea but again we wait and
see what's happening we're hearing more
sirens the sound of more ambulances uh
in the distance as well the odd sound of
an explosion
long way away
but these are really really troubling
and nervous times
okay alex rossi in mario poll take care
down there
it's 7 30 in london which is the
scheduled starting time for the cobra
meeting that boris johnson has called he
will then i'm told speak
in the house of commons make a statement
in the house of commons about what has
been unfolding the awful events that are
unfolding here in ukraine we're also
expecting a news conference from ursula
von der lyon
at the eu we will bring you that as soon
as
that happens but
as you can see there bottom of your
screen cobra meeting underway though
i've got to say it is pretty difficult
to see
what
they can do about this them they impose
sanctions that did not deter
president putin from
what he's done and the threat of even
more swinging sanctions have not
deterred him
from what he is doing today which
appears uh to be
a major assault on this country ursila
vonderlaan is speaking in brussels men
and children are dying
of fear for their lives
we condemn this
barbaric attack
and the cynical arguments to justify it
it is president putin
who is bringing war back to europe
and in these dark hours
the european union and its people
stand by ukraine and its people
we are facing
an unprecedented act of aggression
by the russian leadership against a
sovereign independent country
russians target is not only donbass
the target is not only ukraine
the target is the stability in europe
and the whole of the international peace
order
and we will hold president putin
accountable for that
later today we will present a package of
massive and targeted sanctions
to european leaders for approval
with this package
we will target strategic sectors of the
russian economy
by blocking their access
to technologies and markets that are key
for russia
we will weaken russia's economic base
and its capacity to modernize
and in addition we will freeze russian
assets in the european union
and stop the access
of russian banks to european financial
financial markets
like with the first package of sanctions
we are closely aligned
with our partners and allies the united
states the united kingdom canada but
also for example japan and australia
these sanctions are designed
to take a heavy toll
on the kremlin's interests
and their ability to finance war
and we know that millions of russians do
not want war
president putin is trying to turn the
clock back to the times of the russian
empire
but in doing so
he is putting at risk the future of the
russian people
i call on russia to immediately stop the
violence
and to withdraw its troops from
ukraine's territory
we will not let president putin tear
down the security architecture
that has given europe peace and
stability over many decades
we will not allow president putin to
replace place the rule of law
by the rule of force and ruthlessness
he should not underestimate the resolve
and strength of our democracies
and history has proven
that societies and alliances build on
trust
and freedom
are resilient and successful and that's
exactly what the autocrats fear
the european union stands with ukraine
and its people
we will continue to support them ukraine
will prevail
thank you
these are
among the darkest hour
for europe since the end of world war ii
a major nuclear power
has attacked
a neighbor country
and is threatening reprisals
of any other states
that may come
to its rescue
this is not only the greatest violation
of international law
it's a violation of the basic principles
of human coexistence
it's costing many lives
with unknown consequences
ahead of us
the european union
will respond in the strongest possible
terms
president of the european council
president michel has called for a
meeting
of the european council this evening
and they will agree and provide
political guidance
to adopt
the stronger package
the harshest package of sanctions we
have ever implemented
as high representative for the foreign
affairs and security policy of the
european union
i will be in touch with our partners
around the world
to ensure the international community
will be
fully
grasping the gravity of the moment
and to call strongly
and united on russia to cease
immediately this
behavior
intolerable behavior
and russia leadership will face
unprecedented isolation
this is not a question of blocks this is
not a question of diplomatic power games
it's a matter of life and death
it's about the future of our global
community
and we will stand united with our
transatlantic partners and with all
european nations in defending
this position
we start united
in saying that no violence and
destruction
as means to obtain political gains
we the european union remain the
stronger group of nations in the world
and this should not be underestimated
more immediately
we will be designing
urgent assistance to ukraine
in this dire situation
we will also be active in supporting
evacuations operations
including of our own staff in zones
affected by this russian attack
the european union together with
transatlantic and like-minded partners
have made unprecedented efforts to
achieve a diplomatic solution
to the security crisis caused by russia
but russia has not reciprocated
these efforts
and instead
has opted unilaterally for a grave
and premeditated escalation conducting
the war
president putin
needs to stop this
senseless
aggression and today our thoughts
are with the people of ukraine
we will stand with them
so
there we are
that is the news conference there from
the uh eu ursula vonderlion saying that
this was an unprecedented act of
aggression targeting not only don bass
not only ukraine but the peace and
security of europe
she said they would this unprecedented
act will be met by unprecedented
sanctions we will freeze russian assets
we will implement
sanctions so tough that it will weaken
severely the russian economy and would
take its toll on kremlin interests
we will not let putin tear down the
security infrastructure of europe she
said uh the eu
stands with ukraine and its people and
then joseph burrell uh eu representative
foreign affairs saying that putin must
stop this senseless aggression and also
spoke of unprecedented sanctions
being
imposed
here in kiev we've just heard fighter
jets roaring over
the city not clear who they belong to
but
it is clear a very serious conflict is
unfolding here
chief correspondent stuart ramsey
is also in
kiev and stuart just bring us up to date
with what we know
and what we
don't know and what is not clear because
there's a lot not clear this morning
about what is happening uh one thing is
clear there is a very serious conflict
happening here
there appears to be mark and i i'm just
getting this now um we understand that
four regions are reporting that the
border has been breached and we believe
that is uh russian forces have crossed
in four different regions we understand
uh from the
border security people that
they were attacked with artillery
which you would expect to see uh to to
if you like quieten the situation and
then they were crossing uh the border
you you you heard that jet same as me
pretty loud um a fighter jet for certain
don't know whose side it was but it
appears
that
the russians are invading and that they
are coming
towards kiev
and to
other cities
within the country
we're not sure
exactly where their aims are we have
been told for days now that kiev is is
the number one target we don't know that
is is the case at all but it appears
that it is very much underway uh you and
i were both woken of course
uh with explosions uh around kiev and uh
uh colleagues uh around the country
we're hearing those explosions in the
very early hours of the morning um it
has been calm for a while now but uh
we're still getting reports uh and you
get that sense
that it's building but we we still
haven't
seen much apart from those that that
activity in the early hours of the
morning explosions here uh jets in the
air then helicopters in the air as well
but it has calmed down since
where we're going we just don't know the
western governments uh particularly
united states and great britain have
been warning that this was about to
happen
and today it appears that it has
happened an invasion is underway
but
how it's going to unfold
what effect this is going to have on
ukraine as a country and on the people
we don't know we do know this though
people are very very scared we know that
the motorways out leading out of kiev
towards the west are chock-a-block uh
right now people are very very scared
people are probably
i mean the early part of the day
interestingly people were still coming
to work and commuting as normal that's
calmed down a lot now but many will be
they've been told by their president to
stay at home and i think that's what
many people will be doing waiting to see
what happens are we going to see
uh russian soldiers on the streets of
this capital in the next few hours quite
possibly we just don't know and that is
where we are that is where ukraine is uh
the western world is um
trying to second guess uh president
putin
and trying to work out how big this
invasion is going to be but it certainly
seems that it's it's really underway now
yeah stuart we do have pictures of
other parts of kiev showing
pretty severe
gridlock and people clearly trying to
get out of this capital city of a
country
that is now at war and
these are pictures that um well we
haven't seen i mean the last few days as
i say have been
extraordinarily calm in this capital
city things have just been
progressing normally though with of
course the tension that they've been
living with for
for years
much heightened by
all those troops but
there we are that is one of the main
streets in kiev and
it is
gridlock fear
is taking hold here as
the russian
attack
gets underway joining me now is fabrice
pottier a former head
of policy planning at nato and fabrice
first of all your reaction to what you
are seeing
well it's uh it's a very wary uh picture
uh i i don't know if people are fleeing
careful if it's the usual morning
traffic jam because kf is also known for
that
but the reality is that indeed uh you
feel that ukraine and the ukrainian
people have been left
a bit in between and a bit left abundant
by the west despite all the talks
despite the sanctions despite the unity
of the west the reality is that you
don't have any western soldiers on the
ground
to
be helping their ukrainian
partners
and and basically the ukrainian armed
forces as good as they are and have been
trained and equipped for the past eight
years uh mean little in front of the
military machine that is uh russia right
now so it's it is a pretty
uh a pretty
sad spectacle to look at
and what more can nato
be doing i mean president putin has
invaded an independent
country a democracy that is waiting and
hoping at some stage for nato membership
but what can what more
can nato do about this
unfortunately uh there is not much if
you carry on on the same basis as we
have been operating for the past eight
years which is oh we need to protect
ourselves as the nato members and i
think this is entirely justifiable uh
and at the same time we need to uh
maintain some form of dialogue and
diplomatic track with the russians
while these two things are i think uh
pretty uh sensible they are clearly not
making the difference and the same with
the sanctions that president van de leon
just announced uh it's indeed pretty
impressive that the eu got attacked
together so quickly and i'm sure those
sanctions are pretty powerful but it's
not going to deter putin because putin
is on a mission which is to restore that
old uh kind of soviet empire where
ukraine is in his twisted vision at the
core of it and the only way to stop him
is to respond with force because he's in
the logic of force the problem is we're
not willing to do that we are not
willing to send us french
german british soldier on ukrainian soil
to fight for that and and this he knows
very well and this is why he's uh can go
all the way to kiev if he wants to
and if he does go all the way to kiev he
will
control this country uh he says he
doesn't want occupation but one assumes
his troops would be in this country and
therefore his troops would be on a
border uh opposite nato forces in many
nato's nato countries and that is a
pretty dangerous
situation well it's our i think this is
of the defeat of our own strategy and of
our grand talk of sanctions and and
collective defense is that we could well
end up now with russia literally at our
door
taking on a very significant country but
where you're right is i think putin
knows very well he cannot occupy a
country of more than 40 million people
whose majority do not want to be russian
or do not want to be part of russia they
want to be ukrainian
and and that
occupation is almost will be done at a
huge cost for for russia and russian
armed forces so i don't think this is
his strategy his strategy is to have
enough bargaining
power to impose its terms on whoever is
going to lead
ukraine so that ukraine is not this
democratic free open societies which
basically is the main threat for him
so and instead ukraine will be a docile
uh uh in a way uh aligned uh country
with uh putin's russia
fabrice thank you very much
and you are looking at pictures of a
capital city of a country that is under
attack by vladimir putin's military
the attack began in the early hours of
the morning and this capital city has
yet
to be
attacked from the air but there is
gridlock
and there is heavy traffic and people
are trying
to flee this capital city clearly
fearing that russian troops will at some
stage
make their way
into the capital here it's not clear the
scale of the
attack that uh is underway but we do
know it is serious
and it is uh
a large attack and there the images that
uh you can see
in this capital um fear is taking hold
of people they're trying to get out but
at the moment they can't because it is
gridlock as you can see
and
that is the situation in this capital
where i am let's find out the situation
in the second biggest city kharkiv which
is
way over to the east much closer uh to
the
well it's about 20 miles 30 miles or so
john isn't it from the russian border
what's happening where you are
yeah hi mark it's very close 20 miles to
the border from the center of harkeev
city of about 1.5 million people the
second largest in this country and there
are developments here the national
police of ukraine are reporting a deep
breakthrough of russian troops in the
cherniv
and harkeef regions cherniv is a city to
the east of us it is right on the border
it is both a a city a major ukrainian
city and a region
the border service is saying that the
russians have brought in military
equipment armored vehicles that they
have proceeded through multiple
checkpoints on the border
the border service is saying
that a number of servicemen have been
injured so there are casualties they say
but they are taking all measures to stop
the enemy if you look at the border
service they are lightly armed they will
have light weapons guard dogs lightly
armed vehicles they would not be able to
put up much of a fight against
the russian military but this is a
important development and it gives us an
idea of what the russians are thinking
although president putin has been quoted
by the interfax news agency this morning
saying that he has no plans to occupy
ukrainian territory make of that what
you will i don't think anybody will put
much story in what he has to say anymore
we have heard a couple of artillery
thuds
uh in the last five the last 10 minutes
feeling that russian forces are coming
close we haven't seen or heard much i
have to say i'm just going to pull out
of the way
the center of the city very quiet now
what we have seen is
groups of of men in uniforms carrying
military packs military bags grouping
together in this square and then being
taken away in vehicles the ukrainians
are preparing they will defend they show
every evidence of
being willing and able to
defend
but i think this war this
a special military operation in putin's
words is coming much closer now to this
city
yeah john thank you very much so he has
information there that border crossings
are being breached by russian troops
stewart ramsey a few moments ago was
talking about four
different areas where
there are reports that russian troops
are
breaching the
border of a sovereign independent
country so
president putin can say that he doesn't
want to occupy
ukraine but he is
he is occupying ukraine and his troops
are moving in and he is waging war
on a democratic country in europe
let's speak to the senior fellow on the
transatlantic defense and security
programme at the center for european
analysis
voyager joins me now first of all
what do you make of what's happening
well what's happening is the darkest
hour in european history for the last 77
years
but if anybody was surprised
unfortunately putin and the kremlin had
made their intentions quite clear over
the course of uh
the past several weeks several months
and indeed uh in a strategic sense for
many years they have been trying to
effectively
destroy the sovereignty of ukraine the
largest uh um
country in europe and ultimately what
putin stated uh uh just two days ago to
dismantle uh the statehood of you in any
defense what putin really wants is a
disarmed ukraine that that's that
doesn't turn to the west that follows
moscow's orders effectively a
de facto uh sort of a puppet republic uh
of the russian federation
so effectively
kind of absorbing ukraine
into russia under his control
it will be it will be framed in a
quasi-legalistic way he will be the
impression that this defender
all the entire foreign and security
policy will be for
if put away
this
this
goal in belarus he has
achieved it and apparently now that he
is in the diplomacy that is already
not uh yield
belts he is now
stepped
and move the military stage of the
operation
yeah mark we're having a problem with
the line we let's hope it improves um
why do you think president putin has
chosen now is it because of the state of
the western alliance he's been festering
about this for years why now
all there are multiple factors strategic
international regional
nato has given strong signals to ukraine
since ukraine has been seeking of course
nato and eu membership by the way
uh if nato if ukraine succeed
in joining the western alliance this
will be a death blow to putin's really
imperial project
across eurasia without ukraine russia
will never be in has never been an
empire
um in a in a tactical sense yes this is
this was his last window of opportunity
let's put it that way
uh the usually tactical advances
by russia have taken place in the dry
season in the summer august september
and then in the winter january february
so this is the so-called frozen land uh
period so this is the last uh kind of
days and weeks where heavy uh russian
armor can actually move um across the
the terrain there
uh and of course uh the putin views the
west is being divided
uh weak uh apparently has no respect for
the western politicians you saw how he
treated macron and many others
uh and um he sees the system has the
best moment of opportunity to actually
implement his uh his plan
and if he does what uh
we are thinking he may do
that we'll be redrawing the security map
of europe it will be bringing
russian troops into much closer
proximity with nato troops and how
dangerous do you think that is
well this will be the end of the uh
the global security order as we know it
and i say this extremely responsibly
without any any uh exaggerations uh i
mean effectively putin has killed the
helsinki accords
um and has
brought you know war into the heart of
europe he won't stop there uh the way he
framed this aggression is that he's
actually on a liberating liberating
conquest on on a campaign of liberation
uh he intends to to take down the
ukrainian government which he calls a
nazi
or neo-nazi regime
similar claims he can he can then throw
against any nation in the baltics
they actually have been making such
claims at the u.n level and elsewhere
uh and therefore uh you know the russian
information warfare machine has
sufficient uh tools to actually project
the image of russia defending itself
against
supposedly an aggressive west and
actually expanding its fear perceived
sphere of influence in very much like
stalinist style or catherine the great
uh from the 18th century i mean people
putin
doesn't live in the 21st century his his
perception his
mindset is really set in the in
stalinist times even in the in the 19th
century great spheres of influence he
will not
accept the international order in europe
as it exists anymore and this is a grave
danger to
the european continent and to the to the
west as a whole
okay uh mark voyager uh thank you very
much indeed very worrying uh what you're
saying and uh
thank you for being with us uh this
morning
and uh here in kiev uh well you can see
uh the city skyline there we are hearing
the uh
bells of the cathedral i've got to say
people
in some parts of kiev are just sort of
milling around wondering what on earth
is going to happen
in this city of 4 million people but
there are also extraordinary traffic
jams and gridlock and
people
trying to leave now because the reality
is uh well it's coming home pretty fast
there you can see what is going on huge
queues at petrol stations people trying
to get out of this city presumably
heading west
to towards poland which is a way out as
they fear
the worst a full assault
on this
free
democratic country of ukraine by the
forces of vladimir putin who has begun a
military operation operation in the
early hours
of this morning
against ukraine